AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
HERE TO RESPOND AND RETIRED
BRIGADIER GENERAL ROBERT
SPALDING AND LIEUTENANT COLONEL
JAMES CARAFANO FROM THE HERITAGE
FOUNDATION.
JAMES, YOU BELIEVE THAT BOLTON
WAS ACTUALLY PROMOTING TRUMP'S
AMERICA FIRST POLICIES BUT IF
THAT WAS THE CASE, WHY IS HE
GONE?
>> FIRST OF ALL, MY HEART IS
BROKEN.
IT IS LIKE THE CAPTAIN AND NEIL
BREAKING UP.
I LOVE THE YIN AND YANG BOLTON
AND TRUMP.
THE DYNAMISM WORKED REALLY WELL.
THE FIRST POINT IS, LET'S
REMEMBER BEFORE IT WAS KELLY,
MATTIS, TILLERSON, THEY KEPT THE
PRESIDENT FROM DOING THESE CRAZY
THINGS AND THOSE GUYS ARE
COMPLETELY GONE AND OUR FOREIGN
POLICY IS EXACTLY THE SAME.
NOW THAT BOLTON IS GONE, IT WILL
BE EXACTLY THE SAME.
THAT'S BECAUSE IT'S TRUMP'S
FOREIGN POLICY.
ALTHOUGH IT DIDN'T WORK OUT AND
I'M SAD ABOUT THAT, THERE WERE
THINGS BOLTON REALLY DIDN'T --
PULLING OUT OF INF.
>> Laura: HE WAS GREAT ON
CHINA.
BOLTON ON CHINA, FABULOUS.
WE ARE SIMPATICO ON THAT ISSUE.
SPEAK A REALLY STRONG ON BREXIT,
HELPED PUSH BORIS JOHNSON
ON BREXIT.
>> Laura: YOU SEE WHAT I'M
SAYING, GENERAL?
WITH THE NEWS BROKE, IT DIDN'T
SURPRISE ANY OF US BUT THE MEDIA
ACTED LIKE PENCE RESIGNED OR
SOMETHING.
IT WAS WILD TO SEE THE CHAOS.
YOU WERE THERE WERE McMASTER,
YOU ARE AT THE NATIONAL SECURITY
COUNCIL WHEN McMASTER WAS
THERE SO WHAT DO YOU SAY?
SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT INHERITED
CHAOS.
WE'VE HAD POOR FOREIGN POLICY,
NOT THINKING ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
ON IN CHINA.
BASICALLY INTERVENING JUST ABOUT
EVERYWHERE AND THE PRESIDENT
SAID STOP.
WE'RE GOING TO ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING MORE LIKE OUT OF
EISENHOWER'S PLAYBOOK.
HUSBAND OUR RESOURCES,
STRENGTHEN THE ECONOMY, WORK ON
THE INDUSTRIAL BASE, GET
PREPARED FOR THIS ECONOMIC AND
TECHNOLOGICAL COMPETITION WITH
THE CHINESE AND WE ARE GOING TO
STOP BEING EVERYWHERE, EXCEPT
THE NATIONAL SECURITY'S
ESTABLISHMENT SAID NO.
>> Laura: HAVE THEY NOT
OPPOSED HIM ALMOST EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY?
>> EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
>> PEOPLE FORGET H.R. HAD A GOOD
YEAR.
HE PUT A GOOD STRATEGY ON THE
TABLE.
>> Laura: LA LA LA LA LA.
>> TRUMP IS STILL FOLLOWING THAT
STRATEGY.
>> Laura: I MET HIM.
HE'S VERY NICE.
IT'S NOT PERSONAL BUT IT'S ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT'S AGENDA.
HE WAS ELECTED AS A REPUDIATION
OF BOTH OBAMA AND BUSH ON
FOREIGN POLICY.
I'M SORRY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE, BUSH FRIENDS OF
MINE, LOVE THEM DEARLY.
I WAS A BIG SUPPORTER OF THE
IRAQ WAR I THINK IT WAS A
COLOSSAL MISTAKE.
AFGHANISTAN, WE'VE GOT TO GET
OUT OF AFGHANISTAN.
WE CAN'T STAY IN OR 19 YEARS.
I'M SORRY.
YOU THINK WISHES TO BE THERE
WITH MORE TROOPS?
BECAUSE A POINT ABOUT H.R.
LEAVING WIFE I DID A GOOD JOB
FOR THE TIME AND HE WAS THERE
AND FOR BOLTON, YOUR POINT
IS RIGHT.
THEY ARE NOT MOVING FAST ENOUGH
FOR THIS PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS A   A HAS A PA
THE PRESIDENT HAS A   A HAS A PN
AND HE WANTS RESULTS.
>> Laura: HE IS FINE WITH
OPPOSING VIEWS.
HE THRIVES IN PART ON HEARING
FROM LOTS OF INPUT BUT THEN HE
MAKES A DECISION AND WHEN HE
FEELS UNDERMINED AFTER US,
PEOPLE ARE LEAKING TO THE MEDIA
AND YOU KNOW WHO YOU ARE, THAT'S
WHAT HE DOESN'T LIKE.
I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING FROM
RAND PAUL.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID TODAY ABOUT
THREATS PERHAPS DIMINISHED
AROUND THE WORLD WITH BOLTON'S
DEPARTURE.
WATCH.
>> I THINK THE THREAT OF WAR
AROUND THE WORLD IS GREATLY
DIMINISHED WITH BOLTON OUT OF
THE WHITE HOUSE.
I THINK HE HAD A NAIVE POINT OF
VIEW FOR THE WORLD THAT WE
SHOULD TOPPLE REGIMES EVERYWHERE
AND INSTITUTE DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNMENTS AND WE WOULD MAKE
THE WORLD PERFECT OR REMAKE THE
WORLD IN OUR IMAGE.
FRANKLY, IT JUST DOESN'T WORK
THAT WAY.
>> HERE'S WHERE I DISAGREE.
IT IS TRUMP'S POLICY, NOT
BOLTON.
TRUMP DOESN'T WANT TO FIGHT
USELESS WARS.
>> Laura: BOLTON WASN'T GOING
TO LAUNCH A THERMONUCLEAR
WEAPON.
IT IS THE PRESIDENT'S DECISION
AND THE PRESIDENT MADE THAT
POINT SEVERAL TIMES OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS.
I WANT TO TALK NOW ABOUT WHAT
JIM ACOSTA SAID IN SCOLDING
STEVE MNUCHIN TODAY.
WATCH.
I THINK WE HAVE IT.
>> NATIONAL SECURITY TEAM.
>> THAT'S THE MOST RIDICULOUS
QUESTION I'VE EVER HEARD.
THE NATIONAL SECURITY TEAM WHICH
IS WHAT YOU ASKED, CONSISTS OF
THE NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR,
THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE, THE
SECRETARY OF STATE, MYSELF, THE
CHIEF.
>> Laura: SO HE LISTED ALL THE
PEOPLE IN THE NATIONAL SECURITY
APPARATUS, POORLY UNDERMINING
WHAT THE MEDIA WAS TRYING TO DO
WITH THIS STAFF DEPARTURE WHICH
IS LONG IN THE COMING.
GENERAL.
>> I THINK BACK IN 2014 WE
LOOKED AT WHAT WAS GOING ON
WITH, WHAT WAS HAPPENING WITH
CHINA AND EVERYTHING GOING ON
WITH THESE INTERVENTIONIST WARS
THAT WERE GOING ON AND WE
REALIZED WE NEEDED TO BE FOCUSED
ON BUILDING THE COUNTRY,
BUILDING OUR STRENGTH, AND THE
PRESIDENT, IT WAS STRANGE
BECAUSE 2016, HE STARTS TALKING
ABOUT INVESTING IN THE COUNTRY,
BUILDING THE STRENGTH, TAKING
CARE OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
EVERYTHING WE HAD BEEN LOOKING
AT IN THE PENTAGON.
HE HAS THIS KIND OF SIXTH SENSE
OF WHERE WE NEED TO GO WITH THE
STRATEGY.
I HAVE TO SAY.
>> Laura: THE PEOPLE OF THE
COUNTRY, JAMES, I THINK EVERY
POLL SHOWS THIS.
THEY DON'T THINK IT'S 1994
ANYMORE.
IT'S NOT TOO THOUSAND THREE
WE ARE $20 TRILLION IN DEBT.
AND YET WE HAVE FOLKS, FORMER
BUSH PEOPLE RUNNING WEBSITES
LIKE WE'VE GOT TO PUT MORE
TROOPS IN AFGHANISTAN.
I HEARD IT THE OTHER NIGHT,
MIGHT'VE BEEN ON THIS NETWORK.
I AM MOST FELL OVER.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
THOSE DAYS ARE GONE AND THEY ARE
NEVER COMING BACK.
>> SAYING WE NEED TO TAKE THEM
OUT AND THEN WE NEED TO PUT THEM
BACK IN.
THE DISCONNECT.
WASHINGTON FOCUSES ON THE
PROCESS AND THOSE COMMENTS, WE
DON'T LIKE HIS STYLE POINTS,
WHAT AMERICANS LOOK AT IS HE
DELIVERING AND THEY LIKE THAT
HE'S DELIVERING.
>> Laura: I'VE GOT ONE MORE
THING I WANT TO PLAY IF WE CAN.
I WANT TO PLAY THIS.
CONDOLEEZZA RICE WAS ON "CBS
THIS MORNING."
SHE WAS DOING THE ROUNDS.
SHE HAS A BOOK OUT.
SHE WAS GIVING A BUNCH OF KIND
OF FUN INTERVIEWS AND THIS IS
WHEN I THINK THE PRESIDENT
MIGHT'VE MISSED THIS PARTICULAR
CLIP.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I HAVE SEEN THE RETURN OF
WATER CALLED THE FOUR HORSEMEN
OF THE APOCALYPSE.
POPULISM, I WILL CITE NATIVISM,
NOT NATIONALISM.
ISOLATION AND PROTECTIONISM.
WE HAVE DONE THAT BEFORE.
THE LEAD TO A DEPRESSION AND WA
WAR.
>> THE GREAT DEPRESSION IS HERE.
IT'S BEEN HERE SINCE 2001 WHEN
CHINA AFTER THE WTO.
WE LOST 70,000 FACTORIES,
3.4 MILLION MANUFACTURING JOBS.
WE CAN'T EVEN MAKE CIRCUIT
BOARDS FOR F-35'S.
THAT'S HOW POOR OUR INDUSTRIAL